- Here's the first thing we
just need to get out of the way.
- [Ben] Okay.
- We share a love of the
goddess that is Meryl Streep.
(audience clapping)
Yes, pure love.
- I feel like, does
anybody not have that love?
- No no no,
- and if so, they need to
see a doctor like fast.
- I am creepy in love.
- Yeah, I'm that way.
- And of course, I'll tell you why.
Because I am 30 stars
away from her on the star,
- [Kelly] Get out.
- 30 stars away, 30 stars away.
- That's insane.
I'm pretty bad.
- That is crazy.
You just drop that like, oh.
- Yep.
So I'm closer than you.
- I know.
You know what, you probably
are always gonna be,
'cause I scare her, I'm petty sure.
But I'm okay with it, Ben.
- That's all right.
- I love her.
- I love her too.
- I think she's so fabulous
and you got to work with her
in "Ricki and the Flash".
- I did.
- I know, I saw you.
She was a singer first,
when she was younger.
- 'Cause I know this.
- And when she whips that out,
it's the best, when we get
to see like, "Mamma Mia"
or "Into the Woods."
- [Kelly] Yeah, "Into the Woods", yeah.
- It's amazing, but yeah I
did like two scenes with her
in that movie and I was too
terrified the whole time
to even really even take her in.
But then she came to
see "Dear Evan Hansen"
which is a show that I
was doing in New York.
- I saw that!
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh!
Like, she came to see you!
Were you so nervous?
- Completely.
I added an extra voice lesson
that week, a new haircut.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I got prepared 'cause I got
warning that she was coming.
So I prepared myself.
- I would not wanna know.
- Oh I have to know.